all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy
Alexandra says how can a parent help
motivate their children to engage
interact with their surroundings instead
of pacifying them with phones and
tablets and other glowing screen wait a
minute Alexander who is giving your kids
tablets phones and glowing screens like
they just show up like with a glowing
screen I mean do other kids have a
tablet or anything that they share there
is a we we have so we have some screens
we have a I have an iPad which we all
kind of use there's a single iPad and
then they have Kindles which they use
primarily for audiobooks but also for
watching some TV you know we don't watch
a lot of TV but we watch the kids watch
some TV I mean like we're not as I don't
think I'm as it is mostly yes it is like
PBS is sort of a parent parent
cultivated yeah programming it's not try
things or this Lucille Ball movie so you
know I mean but I talked some about like
what is our evidence on screen time in
the book and I think the answer is like
we don't really know very much about
screens is too new yeah so if you like
want to know like what's the impact of
these screens on like my kids mental
health in high school or their high
school graduation or whatever like it's
just too new to know to know to know the
answers to that and so I think that kind
of leaves it on their parents to sort of
figure out like what you know what's
gonna work with your family what's gonna
work with your with with your kids and I
think that's just about setting this
just about setting the boundaries you're
you're comfortable with yeah you know
I'm comfortable my kids watching a
little bit of you know a little bit of
TV at some you know particularly sort of
structured times mostly on the you know
mostly on the weekend and you know we
use iPad time for rewards basically like
in sort of small chunks as like rewards
for sort of doing your homework
basically you get some small number of
minutes of app time yeah and and that
works for us but it's not the same I
mean it's not that I think that that's
like the right way to do it's just like
that's what we've decided fits inside
the the schedule of life that we that we
want to have yeah I think yeah setting
the boundaries like that's that's how I
look at it it's like you get to choose
when your kids have those things in
their hands so like you and Becks do a
great job with OA I mean
Mariah and I were babysitting her a few
weeks ago when we when you guys left
you're like don't let her watch more you
know them this show that she's watching
yeah and I was like hey Ella let me know
when you're done watching that show and
then we'll do something else when the
show was over surprisingly she was like
alright I'm done
like there was no she didn't try to
sneak more time in but I think that that
speaks to the boundaries that you and
Becks have like gone out of your way to
to set for Ella especially like when Bex
drives out here and elegance the screen
time on the way out and it's funny
because I remember when Rebecca was
saying that to Mariah and I she almost
like it was this guilty thing of like
how she never gets to but you know it
just keeps her quiet and you know I find
it late like it's but it's like dude
she's traveling it's a special treat
like it's totally like it's actually
kind of cool to set up these moments for
your kids to where they can indulge just
a little bit cuz I think you know you
don't wanna be a Luddite you don't wanna
you don't want your kids to be deprived
right so like having you know having
these boundaries set like hey on trips
you get screen time we're having a fun
time it's vacation you get to do this on
vacation or yeah you get to only watch
20 minutes of TV you know a day or
whatever it is but yeah I mean I would
say Alexander like you got to find those
boundaries that are appropriate for you
and your family and stick to those
boundaries it's kind of the key point
right stick and doing yeah I agree I
mean I think one of the things we found
it like it's like there are ways in
which this technology can be like
awesome so like my kids both get really
sick and they become tremendously
carsick in the car so like we can't
watch TV in the car which I would be
totally fine with doing but they turns
out they love audiobooks and so we have
like audiobooks on our Kindles and so we
sit in the car it's like totally changed
our ability to do stuff because we can
drive much further because they're very
happy to like sort of sit and like
listen to you know Ramona Quimby
audiobooks which is totally great Ella
has discovered podcast recently there's
not one what's it called would become
one with guy Roz what in the world yeah
well it's what something like that
people say I haven't had my kids listen
to that people say it's really good yeah
it is she she loves a huge he talks
about it all the time
you